the total banishment of labels and
traditions and Concepts like chivalry
from the dating scene has left everyone
feeling paralyzed and Confused it means
that most single people end up in a kind
of stasis a limbo not knowing whether
they're in a relationship or what to do
if they are in one or what to call it
then nobody knows what to call anything
the fear of commitment that permeates
our culture the aggressive sort of
casualness of everything the insistence
on approaching all matters especially
matters relating to love and
relationships in a way that
diametrically opposes how our
grandparents approached it all of these
factors have made the dating scene not
simply difficult but effectively
non-existent people don't date they just
sort of float along on the cultural
current hoping that they bump into
another piece of debris before moving on
to the next there's no sense of purpose
or meaning certainly there's no clear
Direction